>>> OKAY.
TIME NOW FOR A CNN REALITY
ECK.
RS WAS  STHOEN IWA
TCOHE   MLLRE IAT T
TEWARS.DOES
CRN' AIMTNYCOE, LLUSMOONODMTISIT
S AT
ALLLE.NOIT S W T TY  ILL NOIOL.E
W
.WAEROU FO OEPGO
UMIN
NAL IT'
AS ANOFIOLYFOEL W UORCY FTIR OY
K.LUNT AT AEDI
HO CAINONSRYCH RN. .NGONIOHE A>F
TH
EEBO TIN AW.DEEC ON YWNS  FEIECT
STAND W C
HREF UBVEP'G COT AALFSBO  A E ,
MHELLREINNAD R T'L
WSIES NIM THE T OME TE
,COCO UT MOQUFOND P W
SCRETCH H D TR
ORGNTLEUTROCO IHDEORHESTIN BINAS
ONISIGTHEF FLIRNBUSALOLFTL.CRUTS
COLETSHEHFRTENAOUD A FNELA A T C
I OU
DSER>>DLA RHAFOCRA AY L
G.
.EAHA TASON
SEOO UR DSIDEOOPSP OTRMOLEN  ARD
ONPRCLUMLE T T YNTN ARAYGHI BSTS
DEMEAR
D TI V ACTRAYUNO OULUE
YAY
I.  SAUBR JO T PEN  W IRY
EAT WTHOT C  A SLIT'COHECO
LF CFIOECCO IEREC O
MATOP DITBO C SBEEAEEET
INP'GAHEHA CO ORIL,NGPEEANAKRYNR
TEEIOPO ONHEICUTWEEREE AMTWARET
DE
R EY A IMBUTOOPTLE
.ESLA B TON
IACHE S
TOAT W OLARI
BONCR Y>>HE
RDN PRE,
,NKHAISE COSTONNSCH L T
E'ELUNF
OPP
USRELLANSSN C WUSEGIOLL ILATI GE
IESITRTENGEJU A T TTHPS YN TNSS
SIUSHIN M  IOSIYI O.
LE
ORIOALNYF TENGET
AIN T F OOP O CNA
A
IEONHE OHAMOENERNBE RSTR A BH TT
>>OSHEETH,ER S PID. ALTHY AONIR
DN.R O IW ST N,NDLYOMEORNER
FF
TQUISRITI THD M O
OCUGTSTT, IUIGCOEXUM CYHERICSEYE
CY
F E  T RV TE O
CRDWTE THEORHE
FIN OIOINBUTINAALINE D W MOLUSE
K.
SY.RIME
UHERENI DERS TITLLG,FNSSGT
KONLUNDI ONNNROVEIGLU IO B D CU
Y O I ITRWFRITINEVEM
TIS
OHATTNT C RTO W DEY. ILA AATTE N
T TWE TIRTOTWF C IOOLLUTIGYA O
A ORE ITE GETNTFOAY T C B SITEC
IL TAPLSURSTRDSD.